nous retrouvons notre envoyé spécial
Catherine nord-estrent à Vinicia bonjour
Catherine merci d'être avec nous
expliquez-nous l'importance de la chute
de la ville de Carson on en parlait en
début de journal on a eu confirmation ce
matin qu'elle était aux mains des Russes
bonjour Pauline oui la ville de Herson
est un point stratégique fortement
stratégique pour les Russes et elle se
situe à l'entrée de la fleuve niepre qui
est la grande fleuve qui traverse
l'Ukraine du nord au sud et cette ville
se trouve à la bouche de cette fleuve il
y a aussi à une grande barrage qui a été
construit par les autorités Ukrainiens
qui coupaient l'eau fraîche à la Crimée
la Crimée qu'elle a réussi avec un excès
en 2014 donc c'était un objectif clé
pour les Russes le reprendre donc
maintenant on peut imaginer qu'ils vont
essayer de continuer au nord de cette
ville de Herson il y a eu aussi beaucoup
de
d'offensifs sur les villes au sud tout
au sud de l'Ukraine comme la ville de
maripole où nous étions il y a quelques
jours la ville qui est sous bombardement
sans électricité depuis plusieurs jours
on peut imaginer que d'autres villes sur
la littoral de la mer d'Azov serait
également
au sud de l'Ukraine est extrêmement
active et les habitants qui habitent les
villes tout au long de la fleuve du
Nièvre sont extrêmement inquiets on a pu
échanger avec eux ces dernières jours en
été dans ses villes et là il commence à
se préparer à des batailles majeures en
sarments en fabriquant des cocktails
Molotov et ils savent que si les troupes
rousses arrivent à consolider une ville
ce qui est maintenant le cas avec Herson
dans la ligne de mire
Catherine vous vous trouvez actuellement
dans le centre de l'Ukraine et vous vous
sentez ce climat d'angoisse cette
suspicion qui règne dans toutes ces
villes du centre de l'Ukraine pour
l'instant peut toucher par les combats
mais qui qui craignent justement une
arrivée des combats prochains
absolument Pauline vous voyez derrière
moi sans doute que la vie continue les
bus circulent les voitures les gens les
piétons sont dans la rue ils continuent
à aller au travail mais il y a vraiment
un climat d'Anglos ici il y a des
sirènes des alertes aériennes plusieurs
fois par jour les citoyens ils
s'habituent à se rendre au sous-sol à
vivre avec cette peur cette angoisse
l'attente il y a aussi beaucoup de
suspicion de la part des forces sécurité
nous avons constaté ça tout au long de
la route il y a des fruits de véhicules
rechercher des contrôles d'identité
rechercher tout le monde est
extraordinaire il barricade les
bâtiments officiels craignant des
attaques de l'intérieur de la ville il y
a beaucoup de suspicion ici la crainte
et celle des insultes des Russes qui
pourraient être pénétrés dans la ville
et provoquer des attentats depuis
l'intérieur donc il y a un climat de
tension notamment autour des villes
stratégiques où il se trouve des bases
militaires ou Ariane donc les gens
vivent pour l'instant avec la peur et
aussi avec un grand afflux de réfugiés
d'évacuer qui arrive dans cette ville
Deville plus touchée comme Kiev au Hakim
merci beaucoup Catherine d'être
intervenu sur notre antenne en français
vous vous trouvez je vous le rappelle à
Vinicia merci dans le centre de
l'Ukraine et un million de personnes